morning to you the metropolitan police
are being urged to investigate
allegations of cash for honors
surrounding one of prince charles's
charities the chief executive of the
prince's foundation has stepped down
over claims of an honor being given to a
saudi businessman melinda brady is in
the newsroom for us this morning and
what more can you tell us ander morning
stephen well this is acutely
embarrassing for prince charles because
michael fawcett is arguably his most
trusted aide he has been beside charles
for years he's been working for the
royal family since 1981 and three years
ago he took the title of chief executive
of the prince's foundation that is an
umbrella group for all of charles's
charitable work so michael fawcett
really is a key inner circle for prince
charles and the allegations in several
sunday newspapers today are that
effectively he was
selling access to the prince in return
for donations to various different
charitable projects that charles was
involved in and primarily dumpfree's
house which is an 18th century mansion
in ayrshire in scotland which charles
purchased in 2007 and has spent millions
on refurbishing and the man at the
center of all of this is a saudi
billionaire businessman called dr mafus
mubarak bin mafuze now he was
given an honorary cbe in 2016. he has
made many significant six-figure
donations to the prince's foundation and
other charitable interests that charles
is involved with
a letter published in several sunday
newspapers today from michael fawcett's
office to the office of dr mafus
suggests that where he to continue with
the donations his cbe would be upgraded
to a knighthood and there also would be
support for his application for british
citizenship now mr foster denies any
wrongdoing whatsoever he has now
temporarily stepped aside while this
investigation begins we have a statement
from douglas connell he is chair of the
prince's foundation we can take a look
at that now mr connell says earlier
today michael fawcett offered to step
down temporarily from active duties as
chief executive of the prince's
foundation while the trustees
investigation is ongoing and he
continues the prince's foundation has
accepted this offer
michael fully supports the ongoing
investigation has confirmed that he will
assist the investigation in every way
and we learn also that the scottish
charity commission
they now are looking at this as well and
norman baker the former minister is
urging the metropolitan police to get
involved
okay ender thank you
arau is engulfing the government about
how to pay for social care this week the
prime minister is expected to unveil
long-awaited plans to cap social care
payments but to raise billions of pounds
the prime minister could be forced to
raise taxes and he's already under
pressure from members of his own party
analysis from the institute for
government forecasts that fixing social
care could cost about 10 billion pounds
a year now a one percent rise in
national insurance contributions which
boris johnson reportedly favors would
raise about 10 billion but that would
mean breaking a 2019 manifesto pledge
and raising taxes for about 26 million
working people
our political correspondent rob powell
has more
none of the details have yet been
confirmed officially by
the government but is expected that
national insurance will be the tax that
will be targeted for an increase in
order to pay for the social care reforms
but also for extra money
to help with nhs
backlogs now that is likely to be very
controversial um within the conservative
party because it goes against a
manifesto pledge
in 19 2019 not to up
that tax and i think there is already a
degree of queasiness within the
conservative party stretching into boris
johnson's top team of cabinet ministers
about the prospect of doing that
but equally a number of mps within the
tory party have identified a degree of
political danger in putting up a tax
like national insurance which is not
paid by pensioners and which
disproportionately impacts younger and
lower paid workers in order to pay for
the care
of older people and also to ensure that
they don't have to um
give away and use the sale of a property
and all of the money from that in order
to fund
their care one minister telling me
that it was not um a good uh fit to see
with an across-the-board subsidy like
this uh a few people being uh targeted
to have their assets uh protected one
senior backbencher also said that this
didn't seem like a very conservative
policy while a newly elected
mp said that they were concerned about
the contrast
of safeguarding people's inheritances
while at the same time cutting the
universal credit uplift which is
expected
at the end of the month
the government says no decision has been
made about the future of grenfell tower
despite a sunday times report today
claiming ministers have been due to
announce its demolition a spokesperson
for the housing ministry has said
there'll be no change to the tower
before the fifth anniversary of the fire
in june next year
taliban special forces have broken up a
march led by afghan women demanding
equal rights from their new rulers the
demonstration the second of its kind in
two days in kabul ended abruptly after
fighters fired into the air
outdoor dining could be here to stay as
the government plans to make permanent
some of the changes to hospitality
brought about by the pandemic marquees
in pubs and outdoor street markets could
be allowed all year round
flying at the bournemouth air festival
will go ahead as planned today after a
plane taking part in the event crashed
into pool harbour
two people were rescued from the
aircraft which witnesses told sky news
was carrying a wing walker
ivor bennett reports from bournemouth
look at the left of the screen that
splash the moment a plane crashed at
speed into pool harbour
in slow motion it becomes clear just how
terrifyingly close it came to others
somehow avoiding both the yachts in the
water and the land those who saw it say
a wing walker was standing on top just
moments before
it was just terrifying to watch that the
plane hit the water went went nose first
and then i think the pilot and the wing
walker were submerged for about 10
seconds or so before they uh you know
managed to break free the pilot seemed
seemed very calm as he you know swam to
the rib but the the the poor the poor
girl
you know i was just just screaming um
but
luckily both of them
they they seemed okay
apart from apart from the shock
and um luckily lucky the rib the rib was
there
miraculously both the pilot and wing
walker escaped with only minor injuries
after being pulled from the plane by a
nearby boat just seconds before it sank
then we see a lady appear young girl
here from underneath the aircraft just
the torso screaming obviously in shock
they were dragging them in to the small
boat
this time the the aircraft's actually
sinking
you know i mean it was literally 30
seconds and it was well and
and we thought if they hadn't got out of
there they'd
probably i mean the worst would have
happened it was so frightening
the small aircraft was performing in the
bournemouth air festival and came down
at around four o'clock in a statement
organisers said it is a huge relief for
all those involved in the air festival
that the incident has resulted in the
display crew being removed from the
water safe and well
efforts are now being made to recover
the wreckage which is barely 10 meters
from the harbour
wall it's still not known what caused
the crash but the festival organisers
have said aerial displays will continue
as planned on sunday iva bennett sky
news pool harbour
it's emerged that new zealand had tried
to deport the man who injured seven
people during a knife attack in a
shopping mall in auckland the man who
came from sri lanka was shot dead by
police
three people are still in a critical
condition in hospital
let's get the latest now from the
political editor of tvnz jessica much
mckay
we can reveal today the terrorist's name
as artel samsodine he came here to new
zealand on a student visa 10 years ago
two years later in 2013 he applied for
refugee status saying that he had been
kidnapped and tortured because he's
tamil in sri lanka
now
in 2018 it was discovered that the
documents he used for that were
fraudulent and new zealand authorities
were in the process of revoking that
refugee status and trying to deport him
when the attack took place on friday it
was a four-year battle with new zealand
officials and immigration officials to
try and get that through and highlighted
big gaps in our terrorism laws his
family have also spoken his brother
coming out in a statement saying that
they're heartbroken and shocked by these
actions his mother did an interview with
sri lankan tv saying that her son was
radicalised here in new zealand by his
next-door neighbours now our government
has responded to that saying that he was
a lone wolf and they are not looking for
anyone else in relation to this
the government looks set to overrule its
own vaccine advisors and roll out the
coronavirus jab to 12 to 15 year olds
but it won't be the first european
country to do so
in switzerland for example children as
young as 12 have been eligible for a jab
for more than two months well let's talk
to dr melvin sneakers a vaccinologist
and public health physician
based in zurich good morning to you
good morning stephen
can we get what's your assessment on how
effective these vaccinations are for 12
to 15 year olds
so um these vaccines have been assessed
for for safety and efficacy in in
children 12 to 15 years of age and
we have seen that the immune response
in these age groups are similar to the
immune response in older individuals
what are you doing in terms of the
number of jabs i mean is it do they get
double jabbed at that age or is it a
single injection they get the same
amount of vaccination stephen
you see over here there's certainly been
discussion about a single injection or
even potentially half a dose for that
sort of age group seeing that just
wouldn't wouldn't have the same efficacy
well
there are other things to consider as
well because you could also look at
whether these kids have been exposed to
source cove to in in the past because we
also have seen that those who have been
exposed to stars go to in the past um
and given um one dose of
um the copic vaccine they have um better
immune responses to those who were not
exposed in the past
what do you make them
what's your understanding of the
decision by the joint committee on
vaccination and immunisation here which
advises the british government on these
things when they
when they when they sort of just have
voted
against that against recommending it for
that age group
so from what i understand um they were
very clear in saying that um the margin
of benefit is considered too small to
support universal vaccination right so
they're not saying not to give it to um
children age 12 to 15 but to give it to
those with um
conditions like blood cancers sickle
cell disease diabetes
congenital heart disease and many others
so it's not really saying not to give it
to these children so it's it's clear
that for these children the risk of
the the
the benefit of the vaccine is
significantly higher than um
not getting the vaccine basically in
the potential for
covid infection
well
for those children yes but i mean they
will be getting vaccinated anyway at
some point but it's it's for everybody
else i mean it's a i mean they're saying
that the the benefit is is so marginal
it's not worth having for everybody else
well they are saying that at the moment
um
the data is not yet enough for them um
to consider this to to give the vaccine
to everyone right they also mentioned
that it's difficult to factor in
long-covet because
the
the
um they don't know at the moment how
common uh long cove it is in this age
group but it's also um
um
good to highlight that they
they mention that their advice does not
include wider issues such as disruption
to schools right so it's not that
they're giving this as an advice
scientific advice but if you look at
a bigger the bigger picture for example
um then the ministers could consider
seeking separate advice on this
i mean what have um what what sort of
impact has it had in switzerland what
sort of take up has there been within
that age group
um
the uptake i would say could be better
but at least some of the kids are now
getting vaccinated um it also depends on
in the parents because in switzerland um
there is a high number of anti-vax
anti-vaxxers i would say so um
not as good as in countries like france
for example um or brazil but it's it's
it's getting better i would say
okay dr sneakers good to talk to you
this morning thank you thank you stephen
well let's have a look at the latest
covert data for you for the uk there's
been a further 37
578 new cases reported in the last 24
hours and a further 120 people have died
that takes the total number of deaths to
133
161. another 33 000 first doses of a
vaccine have been given 108 000 second
doses have been given which means 43.25
million people are now fully vaccinated
just to remind you that trevor phillips
on sunday returns later this morning
he's going to be talking to amongst
others the vaccines minister nadim
zahawi that all starts at half past
eight
but now let's have a look at the weather
for you
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well temperatures are set to rise in the
late summer sunshine over the next few
days but there's going to be some rain
in the north and west today most places
having a dry start just a few showers
the western fringes of ireland northern
ireland and the western isles warm sunny
spells developing widely across britain
this morning although it's going to be
rather gray and misty around those
cornish coasts and the channel islands
bright spells for northern ireland and
the republic but outbreaks of rain will
spread in from the west that rain may
turn heavy at times as it spread
eastwards across northern ireland and
into parts of scotland during this
afternoon
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
google maps for graves that's the aim of
a new project which will help people
trying to find where their ancestors are
buried it's going to visit each of the
church of england's 19000 graveyards and
the plan is to photograph and map every
headstone grave and memorial fraser
moored has been finding out more
it's a mammoth task
mapping photographing and referencing
millions of gravestones in thousands of
graveyards the goal to provide a digital
map of burial sites and records that
will be invaluable to historians and
genealogists and fascinating to the
public
we're here in barton churchyard near
penrith in cumbria and there we can see
the headstones we can see the trees we
can see the graves and again imagining
we're overseas somewhere there we have a
photograph
of that very headstone that we can see
here
obviously these are now protected
because there's
numerous stories of records being lost
through fire or theft or floods up here
in particular for example so they could
be lost with flooding we also have a
copy of the original burial register so
they're protected and also having them
online means people are not having to
manhandle them so they're not being
they're not deteriorating through
through heavy use and abuse and that
sort of thing and as you say they're
accessible from anywhere in the world
exactly
the backpacks the team used to collect
the data cost a hundred thousand pounds
each and contain five cameras two laser
scanners and the latest gps technology
it may only take an hour or so to scan a
graveyard like this but with 50 million
measurements being gathered it can take
up to a week to process that information
and with nineteen thousand graveyards to
be mapped the seven year time scale for
this project
could be a tight one
once the initial data has been fed into
the system the local parishes themselves
can keep the online records updated the
survey put into context everything
within the churchyard the building the
headstones and even the vegetation and
what we learned at that point was where
the old maps weren't exact in in scale
in detail so we've had that immediate
advantage
there are benefits for ecologists
biologists and botanists too the data
gathered by this study will also be used
as part of a national biodiversity
survey of the sometimes very rare plants
and animals that are living amongst our
dead
fraser moored sky news penrith
now the uk is set for a rise in
unemployment when the furlough scheme
ends though recruitment figures are
expected to stay strong the resolution
foundation predicts that about 150 000
jobs could be lost but it praises the
furlough scheme saying it's protected
more than 11 million jobs so let's talk
to research director at the resolution
foundation greg thwaites good to see you
this morning so
a bit of a bumpy ride ahead then
yes the fellow scheme's been very
successful in protecting people's jobs
it protected over 11 million jobs
throughout the crisis and this was
during the worst recession for 300 years
in the uk now as the furlough scheme
comes to an end at the end of this month
we still have maybe one and a half
million people on furlough and the big
question is what happens to them now
well what is going to happen to them
well some of them will hopefully find
new work because we've got a great deal
of uh hiring going on hiring at record
rates in the uk but we think that some
of them are likely to become unemployed
and therefore unemployment will stop
falling and maybe start to rise again
and therefore it's crucial that the
government supports these people in
their job search and in particular
doesn't go ahead with the benefit cut
that it's planning at the end of this
month i mean it's interesting because
i mean the the way you talk there is an
assumption that every one of those 1.5
million people on furlough are not going
to be kept on by their the business
they're working for which isn't true is
it i expect some of them will be kept on
but the economy's been more or less open
for a couple of months now and these
people are still on furlough so it's
likely that some of those people are
still are being kept on furlough because
they don't have jobs to go back to not
all of them but some of them it's also
very striking that whereas at the
beginning of the furlough scheme most of
the people on furlough were young they
were disproportionately very young
people
we now see a lot of older workers are on
furlough they're the ones who are
disproportionately left on furlough and
those people when they lose their jobs
older people it tends to be very serious
for them and they may be slightly less
adaptable they might have to take bigger
pay cuts they may have more
responsibilities so it's serious for
anyone when you lose your job but if you
lose your job when you're older and you
need to maybe move house or move into a
different industry that can be very
tough yeah well look i mean i i don't
want to underestimate how how tough it
is on on the personal
front and if you're going through that
you know you you've got our sympathies
however looking at just looking at the
figure the cold hard facts if you like
um you know there is still a a strong
recruitment in the uk isn't it we know
there are jobs there are plenty of jobs
available
this should be a time of
buoyancy by next year shouldn't it
well i i certainly think there's good
reason to believe that hiring will
continue to stay strong you're right
that there are many vacancies record
vacancies but some of those vacancies
aren't in the same places or in the same
industries as the workers who are either
unemployed or who might be about to
become unemployed in the next few months
and it's going to take time for people
to to retrain and to find those new jobs
and over that period of time that's the
period when we might see unemployment
rise
and stop falling
i mean you talk about the um
the 20 pound a week increase in
in universal credit i mean it it's
a bit unrealistic isn't it to x because
that's an across the board payment
because it's the cheapest way of doing
it that is it
it's unrealistic isn't it to expect that
to stay
um
for for everyone who's claiming that
benefit isn't it
i don't think it's unrealistic i think
it would cost a few billion pounds a
year at a time when you know last year
the government borrowed uh over 300
billion pounds and the economy is worth
like two and a half thousand billion
pounds uh so it is not an unaffordable
sum of money and we need to remember
that lots of that money goes to people
who are in work and it's just supporting
them to top up their wages or to people
who who can't work as well as people who
are looking for work so i think it's an
achievable sum we've afforded it over
the past year and i think we can afford
it we can afford to keep it up if we
don't um
keep the benefit going if we cut
benefits uh like the government is
planning to do that would be one of the
biggest benefit cuts in like 90 years
but it was only ever brought in as a i
mean you saw a benefit cut it's
realistically it's not a benefit cut is
it because it was only ever brought in
as a temporary measure
it was it was brought in as temporary
but it's done a great job of
limiting the the hardship that's that's
happened over the crisis because while
the follow scheme protected lots of jobs
it didn't protect everyone and we're
going to see i'm afraid to say a little
bit more hardship as the furlough scheme
comes to an end and like we're saying in
the report not everyone moves into work
so we don't think the times now the time
is right to cut this benefit now
so a couple of billion pounds you say
isn't it a lot of money there's
a lot of struggle at the moment seeing
how the government is going to try to
raise 10 billion pounds a year to pay
for this change in social care which i
mean desperately desperately needed this
sort of overhaul and obviously national
insurance looks like it it could be the
way forward in that what does the
resolution foundation think
we certainly think that um social care
needs more money uh
it doesn't have enough resources it's
rationed too much you don't you don't
that you have to be too seriously um
in need before you get it and we so we
think that taxes or national insurance
are going to have to rise in order to
pay for higher social care the problem
with just national insurance is that you
don't pay it uh once you're at state
pension age so the people who maybe you
you might be a millionaire uh but a
retired millionaire and pay no national
insurance you don't pay it on um
non-wage income so you don't pay if you
receive rents or profits it's only paid
on wages and it's only paid on wages
earned by people and who are lower than
the state pension age and then it's also
paid by people on lower incomes than
income taxes so we don't think it's a
fair way to raise more money we think
income tax would be much better
and yet if i mean if you talking 10
billion pounds over
um
what is it 26 million working people i
mean if we took out the money that
employers make and made this a you know
a flat payment by everyone it's still
less than 80 pence a week
so this is one of the reasons we think
that money should be you know money
should be raised by the government to
pay for social care we certainly agree
that that needs to happen and we're
encouraged that the government is
looking at how to do it but we think
income tax is a much fairer way it's
paid um but not by people who are on
very low in earnings and it's paid by
people irrespective of their age when
they earn money rather than than
national insurance which like i say you
don't pay if you're on state pension age
or above
okay greg threats from the resolution
foundation
well it's time for the papers this
morning with anthropologist mary anna
hotter and deputy editor of spiked tom
slater and
mary anne
last time we're going to see you for a
little while
i'm sorry to i'm sorry to say
i know um i'm going off on matt leave uh
because i've got a very big baby bump
just off camera
um oh well look enjoy
thank you i will be back don't worry oh
yeah well it's just been nice that cole
won't be on his own now he's gonna have
a little brother or sister that'll be
nice
name oh can i i remember today he's a
cutie he's a cutie okay tom let's kick
off with the observer looking at the
cabinet row over afghanistan
yeah so tobias elwood who's the chair of
the commons select defense committee is
calling for an end to this pretty
unseemly row which is broken out between
dominic rob the foreign secretary and
ben wallace the
head of heading up the ministry of
defense which is obviously broken out
since the fall of afghanistan so on one
hand you've had dominick robb coming
under a lot of fire for staying on his
holiday in crit as kabul
fell
suggesting that really the problem was
intelligence and also shifting some of
the blame really over towards the army
and towards the ministry of defence ben
wallace since hitting back suggesting
that he knew in july that this is how
things were going to pan out and that
therefore dominick raj
implying heavily that he really
shouldn't have been away and also
bringing the foreign office under a lot
of criticism for getting diplomats out
whilst leaving ministry of defense staff
and the army to deal with the processing
of visa applications for afghan refugees
so i think it is incredibly unseemly as
tobias elwood says i mean first of all
there's plenty of blame to go around i
mean this was a
really colossal failure of military
intelligence yes a general strategy of
20 years of
nation building really so much blood and
treasure expended towards building a
state that collapsed in a number of days
but also just in terms of there were a
lot of people who have fell asleep at
the wheel as cardboard fell you know the
leading civil servants in the foreign
office in the ministry of defence and
the home office were all on holiday
along with dominic rob not together but
at the same time in different places as
kabul fell so i think for this to kind
of descend into a pretty unseemly spat a
kind of westminster discussion about who
who's up and who's down and there's rob
on the way out
i just think it feels like a bit of an
insult really to the people who've been
affected
by this tragedy on the ground
okay uh marianne to the sunday telegraph
um
another war in the conservative party
this time over tax increases
yeah exactly and it's probably going to
get unseemly again
um
yeah they've got a lot of they've got a
lot of blame to go around so this is
about the um proposed tax rights or
national insurance contribution rises
that are going to be introduced um rishi
sunak the chancellor and boris johnson
are going to probably affect not to push
back not just from the electorate but
also from uh people within their own
party
so the whole principle is new nhs and
social care levy and your your previous
skeptic resolution foundation is talking
about this as well how do we
pay the bills because the bills are
enormous there's uh going to be about 30
million people on nhs waiting lists
waiting for elective procedures
scams all that kind of everyday business
of the nhs um
that has been put on hold because of the
the pandemic now we're looking at going
into the winter season where perhaps
some people might need uh covered
boosters we're going to have to have um
you know flu jab roll out but also all
the regular stuff that has been put off
that might be more serious because
people haven't been able to see doctors
or dentists or other health care
professionals for
almost two years now
so
the uh so the the government are
suggesting that the proposal that that's
kind of circulating at the moment is
that they will add perhaps at least one
pence possibly more to national
insurance contributions and as the guy
from the resolution foundation pointed
out that is a blanket tax on um
employees earnings as well as employers
so it will affect small and medium
businesses as well as large businesses
because of what they're paying in as
well
and it kicks in a very very low level
it isn't taxed on rental income it isn't
taxed on investment income it isn't
taxed for anyone over the state pension
age and so there will be lots of people
who are richer better off and able to
pay more into the shared pot to pay for
social care to pay for the nhs to pay
for all those things that we as a
country need
but they won't be paying people on low
incomes who are going to be hardest hit
and stephen you said it's only 80 p a
week it's okp a week for you or me
because i can probably afford that but
lots of people who are literally
counting every penny to make sure that
that stays over their heads that the
lights stay on their kids have food in
the fridge in the morning
a week is a lot it really does add up
and
so the conservative party members
themselves are actually saying you know
this is going to impact support on the
red wall so all that
sort of traditionally labor seats that
shifted over the to the conservatives in
the last election
um one mp who isn't or a cabinet
minister actually who isn't named says
it was it's morally economically and
politically wrong to be looking at
national insurance contributions rather
than some other kind of of taxation so
it's going to be
proud yeah yeah going to be interesting
to see how that plays out in the next
week um tom there's all this talk about
getting young people to to get their
vaccinations concerns about take up what
doesn't help
is if they have to travel miles and
miles and miles to get their jab which
is what the sunday mirror is talking
about this morning
yes an extraordinary story in the sunday
mirror here so as you were saying 16 17
year olds have been urged to get jabbed
there's been this big grab a jab
campaign and yet a number of young
people are finding that when they go on
this nhs website to find out where their
nearest center is where they can get
vaccinated in some cases being asked to
travel as much as 70 miles to go and get
this done so there's there's one 16 year
old from hornsey in east yorkshire who
was offered leeds or grimsby as
prospective places to get vaccinated so
70 and 50 miles away respectively and
it's just another huge
unforced error it feels like on the part
of the government and the rollout which
is expending so much kind of energy and
trying to make sure that young people
get vaccinated widening the number of
people who can get vaccinated in terms
of young people but failing to make this
straightforward given the fact that a
lot of the nhs sites that do exist for
vaccinating people are over 18's only at
the moment so in the story um some
government sources push back a little
bit that they're building out capacity
that some of this might have just been
glitches on the website but it's
certainly not a good look and certainly
not helpful when you're trying to push
as many younger people to get vaccinated
as possible less for their own health
but for the health of those around them
this certainly doesn't help matters no
no it doesn't we've just got about 90
seconds squeezing a couple of papers
the observer online marianne has got
pupil premium and and the number of
children who are going to miss out
yeah so this is a story about um how the
pupil premium funding so the extra cash
that goes to children who are coming
from um less well-off backgrounds is
accounted for and basically the
government have shifted it so they're
not measuring um the number of pupils
the school has in january of the year
they're measuring it from the previous
october so 60 000 pupils and therefore
the schools that that support those
pupils are going to lose out on funding
there's one school in haringey in london
that's going to lose almost 45 000
pounds worth of money because um the
government aren't going to count the
pupils who are actually enrolled for
september because they're counting for
the ones that were there 11 months
previous yeah it's it's just
again an unforced error as tom says
lies damned lies and statistics all this
sort of thing isn't it in a strange way
let's just finish off then 30 seconds
tom uh the yorkshire woman who
got brexit done as it were
exactly um so uh yorkshire woman has
earned her place in history as it turns
out that linton crosby so the tories br
the election supreme pointed out that
this slogan wasn't the brainchild of
dominick cummings or boris johnson or
anyone but actually a woman in a focus
group in yorkshire who came out with
this perfect free woe slogan that many
people credited with winning the last
election so yeah great story of one
person who's got their place in history
it turns out yeah
yorkshire plain talking that's what it
is get it
i can just i can hear it now really good
to see you both this morning mary ann
we'll see you in a few months